According to the USPS, mail can be considered
“undeliverable” due to a number of factors
ranging from insufficient postage to the person
it’s addressed to refusing to accept it.
Regardless of the reason the mail cannot be
delivered, the USPS states that: “All nonmailable
pieces are returned to the sender.”
This seems like a pretty cut and dry statement
that leaves very little room for interpretation.
However, there’s always an exception to
the rule and in the case of undeliverable
mail that exception is things like periodicals,
which are deemed to have little to no value
after a certain point due to their timely
nature and will be disposed of accordingly.
That said, publishers can request to have
such items returned to them if they so wish.
So what about the case of mail that is undeliverable
and happens to have no visible or legible
return address?
The Postal Service has had measures in place
to deal with these so-called “dead letters”
almost since the service first began in earnest
in the 1700s with the awesomely named position
of Inspector of Dead Letters, being created
by an act of Congress way back in 1777.
The first Dead Letter Office, on the other
hand, wouldn’t exist until 1825, when the
sheer amount of dead mail necessitated the
creation of a dedicated service to deal with
it all.
Today, undeliverable mail without a return
address will be pre-processed by postal workers
and, unless it doesn’t meet certain criteria
which we’ll discuss in a moment, will be
sent to the Mail Recovery Center in Atlanta.
(Up until 1992, the Mail Recovery Center was
officially known as the Dead Letter Office,
but the USPS opted to change it to better
reflect the ultimate goal of returning mail.)
In any event, as noted on their website, the
Mail Recovery Center generally doesn’t accept
anything worth less than about $25 or something
that can’t reasonably be traced back to
someone like keys, cosmetics and food.
In this case, the items will either be recycled,
disposed of or in some cases, donated to charity.
Of course, exceptions can and will be made,
but this is handled on a case-by-case basis.
For example, if an undeliverable letter or
package contains something that clearly has
sentimental value (such as photographs or,
in one case, postal worker Lori Ferguson-Costa
had the pleasure of processing a dead-package
containing a jar that in turn contained a
placenta) , it will be processed to try to
track down the original sender or intended
recipient, despite it having no real monetary
value.
You might at this point be wondering what
about if they find money and despite their
best efforts they can’t track down who sent
the letter or where to send it to?
It will simply be tallied up and given to
the US treasury.
So what goes into the “processing” step?
First, a Mail Recovery Clerk has to physically
open the letters and packages to discern exactly
what they contain, making people in this position
just about the only individuals in the US
legally allowed to open another person’s
mail without it being a federal crime.
As you can imagine, this means security is
tight and everything the clerks find has to
be meticulously recorded and noted down to
stop someone just walking out of the building
with a pocketful of other people’s stuff.
Beyond just opening the packages and letters,
the mail clerks in question will go to fairly
extensive lengths to try and return or deliver
dead mail.
In one case noted in a Smithsonian piece on
the day in the life of one of these workers,
the worker at the center of the article, Vera,
opened a package with no identifying marks
whatsoever on the outside, but managed to
use a phone number contained inside to ultimately
track down the package’s original owner.
In another case, the aforementioned postal
worker Lori Ferguson-Costa got a call from
a woman who’d recently had her baby die
of SIDS.
(If you’re curious, see: What Causes Sudden
Infant Death Syndrome.)
The woman, who was in tears at the time, explained
that she’d mailed a photograph of her baby
that she didn’t have any copies of, the
last one taken before the baby’s death,
but the recipient (the grandmother) never
got it.
Lori then got a detailed description of what
was in the photograph and after a pretty extensive
search around the Mail Recovery Office manged
to find it, despite going off of only the
woman’s description of the picture.
Essentially, any clue whatsoever, even small
ones, in the package will be followed up on
until the clerk manages to find out where
the package was intended to go or who sent
it.
As for how long this all takes, the usual
amount of time the Mail Recovery Office will
hold things varies and is handled on a case-by-case
basis depending on the item and the clerk’s
preference.
For example, if the item in question is clearly
worth a lot of money or seems like it probably
holds significant sentimental value like a
wedding dress or jewellery, the Mail Recovery
Office will hold onto it for upwards of a
year (and in some cases even longer, such
as a jar containing the cremated remains of
one W.C.G.
McLeod who lived from 1891 to 1977, which
postal worker Vera stated was there when she
got the job and she intends to keep it around
until she retires, hoping someone will claim
it).
However, since it just isn’t feasible for
the Mail Recovery Office to hold onto something
indefinitely, in the vast majority of cases,
after every avenue to return something is
explored and they’ve held onto an item long
enough for someone to miss it and file a claim,
they are left with no choice but to sell it
at in a bulk auction, the profits of which
are funneled back to the Postal Service.
So with all their efforts, how successful
are they at bringing dead mail back to life?
According to official figures, they are able
to deliver or return 68% of the dead mail
“with obvious value“, a figure which drops
to a lower, but not insignificant 43% when
you factor in all dead mail.
When you consider that only about 0.05% of
mail is deemed “undeliverable” in the
first place, that’s a pretty remarkable
overall delivery rate.